foreign
tens of millions of garments are tossed
out to make way for the new for
consumers they are out of sight out of
mind but the reality is much Messier
some of the discarded clothes enter a
global second-hand supply chain that
works to prolong their lives but the
rise of fast fashion is making the
process increasingly difficult
[Music]
Ghana was the world's biggest importer
of used clothing in 2020 and here at
Cantonment to Market in Accra the
capital of Ghana millions of governments
arrive every week in massive bills the
market wholesalers and resellers do
their best to try and sell as much as
they can but there's just too much
clothing it's unsellable some 40 of what
enters Continental is believed to live
here as waste creating a burden on the
city
with the rise of fast fashion garments
fall apart after a few washes cheap
synthetic Blended Fabrics are difficult
to repurpose and people are buying and
throwing away too quickly since 2000 the
average number of times a garment is
worn before it's discarded has plummeted
by 36 percent globally only less than
one percent of old clothes are recycled
into new ones
this is one of the largest used clothes
recycling Factory run by kanam
International in Gujarat India
your workers soar through piles of
different garments and Grading them into
different categories it's a complex
process that extracts maximum out of
used clothes and prolongs its life but
ultimately very little of it is recycled
Can-Am International takes up to 120
million pounds a year of used textiles
from North America Europe Japan and
Australia much of it gets chopped up and
turned into things like car insulation
mattress filling and cleaning cloths but
at some point these products still end
up in a landfill or incinerator
according to the UN the fashion industry
contributes between two percent and
eight percent of global carbon emissions
companies are considering alternative
models that include capping growth
focusing on fewer higher quality items
and narrowing inventory to
climate-friendly options though it's
unclear how these approaches scale over
time
[Music]